[Music]
for centuries this used to be the
European Way in the 20th century twice
we Europeans tried to commit collective
suicide and this is the results if fear
takes over in society if hatred of the
other becomes a norm this is where we
end up neighbors lying together in the
cemetery would fought each other and
killed each other in two world wars
Europe has learned this lesson this is a
mistake we need to avoid every time when
we are challenged this is a risk we run
how do we respond to that extreme
nationalism no I strongly believe that
the answer to the challenges of today
which are many fold such as terrorism
based on jihadism is not to fall for the
temptation of fear is not to fall for
the temptation of hatred for the other
nationalism is like alcoholism a short
period of exaltation followed by long
period of headaches
nationalism mixes for because it's
Siamese twin protectionism will destroy
the internal market and disrupt
international trade nationalism makes
sweet because it's eternal seeking of
enemies
it's the stain of others its need to
feel superior makes cooperation with
other nations to collectively guarantee
our freedom and security much more
difficult
so if nationalism makes us poor weak and
morally and secure how can it claim to
be patriotic I maintain that
nationalists are unpatriotic a true
patriot is proud of his nation wants it
to be strong peaceful prosperous values
based to achieve that a true patriot
knows he needs unity he once open its he
craves cooperation with others he sees
the strength found in compromise debate
and unity to be a patriot is to be
European to be European is to be a
patriot
[Music]